meine damen und herren es bereits und
sind der eigenen echte freunde um di
luca peter 2 das ist schon gegessen
damit nicht alles falsch rüber wie pizza
ist ja auch ligaweit ich draußen sondern
sie kommen ja erst übermorgen am montag
zum sind dann alle räte berg hinein da
haben schon sehr viele rewe märkte die
playstation im sortiment haben sich zum
beispiel oder leute brehme und da liegt
ja einfach so tiefkühlregal voll und
einer pizza das kann ein playboy
shooting hier schon zwei tage vor dem
eigentlichen release in supermärkten
kann daran liegen dass er bestimmte
regel märkte gestellt haben steuer
bekommen habe ich bin ich aber auch
nicht weiter stimmen
es reicht ganz cool ich habe viele
bilder von euch gesehen die leute die
schon gegessen haben und so ist es auch
kein so krasses geheimnis wenn meine
damen und herren das was ich die ganze
zeit wie einen alten beute und auch wenn
sie eigentlich geheim gehalten aber das
macht die luca getan so des sommers und
unterscheidet sie von anderen
tiefkühlpizzen beide werden und hätten
die user prinzip gerade
hier ist spaß
die erste pflichtaufgabe zusammen mit
meinen träumen kann muss da bewusst
sogar eine vegetarische geriet an einem
weißen karton mit dem des rates
meiendorf deswegen muss jetzt gesagt ein
jahr später
wir machen den karton diesmal nicht
sondern komplett starts ihr fragt euch
jetzt vielleicht handy ist denn diese
pizza als so sieht's jetzt aus der
offenheitsgrad vor
falls ihr euch die pizza perfekt machen
wollte ofen ober unterhitze 250 c
vorheizen in der zeit die plätze
aufkommen lassen dann rein die plätze
sechs bis zehn nach neun minuten finde
ich schmeckt super perfekt so spitzer
tutorial mit luca
einige von euch fragen sollten herrchen
warum ist denn die pizza eine ganze
weile prosciutto nur dateien schwarz das
liegt ganz einfach an der pflanzlichen
aktivkohle die wir drei angepackt haben
deswegen die pizza wir können ich habe
jetzt zum thema aktivkohle doch mal hat
jetzt einige fragen sollte haye
irgendwie steht nicht oder so nein auf
keinen fall die uhr hat einerseits eine
unbedenklichkeitsbescheinigung dazu
unterschrieben und ihr könnt ja auch
einfach in der apotheke irgendwie aktiv
kohletabletten kaufen die dann eben die
gegen durchfall sind und dieses ganze
magen darm wegen der regel diese pizza
ist also tatsächlich gesünder als andere
pizzen der auf ist auf jeden fall fertig
vorgeheizt freunde werden wie gesagt auf
250 grad ober unterhitze vorfeld zu
lassen
die pizza aufgetaut also ein wenig
angetaut direkt auf das wieder nur das
gitterrost rost legen also ich weiß
nicht ich mache das immer so und bei
einer gehzeit von 85 80 stunden macht
lieber so acht minuten eigentlich und
das als wir warten jetzt acht minuten
und in der zeit habe ich noch mal kurz
eine kleinigkeit sagen dielen neu zu
haben in die kommentare geschrieben hey
luca eine luca besser 2 haben einige
leute meinen auch dass sie nicht dadurch
ausgeschlossen gefühlt haben aus meiner
community weil sie halt die pizza essen
können
die sache ist ganz einfach leute bei
meiner ersten blitze haben wir eine
vegetarische kürzer gemacht also eine
pizza margherita und da ich selber pizza
prosciutto über alles feier mit dem
hinterschinken und mit den
sonnengereiften tomaten und mit dem
mozilla der darauf gestaltet haben dass
halt gedacht machen war jetzt das
es tut mir leid aber vielleicht luca
pizza 3
ich habe gefragt im capitol wie pizza
eigentlich sein das kommt tatsächlich
ganz auf den supermärkten verkauft
es gibt immer mehr gedacht dass wir
schon gesehen für 369 es gibt
supermärkte für 39 90 helfen wirklich
komplett auf den supermarkt alles kommt
auf aktionen haben die gerade laufen
aber
da wirklich waren gerade mit dem anderer
kostet 379 also komplett unterschiedlich
aber irgendwie so in dem rahmen es gibt
andere pizzen die kosten vielleicht 40
cent würde ich dich kaufen es ist
natürlich immer geschmackssache aber ich
beispielsweise laut zu sagen wusste also
dass unternehmen mit denen ich dieter
herstelle gelegen sehr sehr sehr sehr
großen wert auf qualität die wir jede
pizza ist vom rand gemacht also das ist
jetzt nicht maschinell jede pizza sie
gleich sondern jede pizza sie
tatsächlich ein bisschen anders aus
washington liegt lose obendrauf der käse
liegt darauf das heißt also letztendlich
alles von hand gemacht wir haben
pflanzliche zutaten die aktivkohle 20
kommt extra aus den niederlanden das ist
wirklich qualitativ soll das an eine
echte italienischen pizzeria besitzer
anknüpfen und dies hat auch riesig und
schmecke krankl und die schwarze
janukowitschs einfach ästhetisches
gebiet die pizza hut fertig meine damen
und herren di luca peter 2 ist
tatsächlich erst das hier zehnte mal
dass ich dir jetzt esse
[Musik]
schwimmen fahrrad hier durchfahren
hammer ist tatsächlich die einzige
spitze werde ich den rampe das hier ist
nun also di luca pizza 2 ich weiß nicht
es die pizza offenbar so ich glaube die
immer so zusammen
bevor ich hier rein weiße falls sich
immer fragen sollte haye schmeckt die
pizza jetzt anders weil da aktivkohle
drin ist und das irgendwie bekömmlicher
zu machen oder so nein die pflanzen gut
ist geschmacksneutral und der teig
schmeckt jeder andere tag auch als ich
meine überzeugt euch selbst hofft
vermeidende pizzateig ihr euch mit
kumpel mit einer freundin und dann könnt
ihr einfach probieren und wenn ihr sie
feiert dann wird es mich sehr freuen
wenn sie nicht weit
es ist halt geschmackssache ditto das
richtig gut
[Musik]
natürlich sagen jetzt das engagement ist
doch meine pizza aber die schmeckt echt
geil david will stürmer probieren
das ist mir egal wenn man gerüche oder
so war als video übertragen können aber
ich glaube das geht noch nicht oder
also meine damen und herren das hier ist
die mutter pizza 2 werden die auf jeden
fall gleich noch auf essen
so ist der karton aus eigentlich haben
übermorgen aber ich glaube da gibt es
auch tatsächlich heute schon in allen
möglichen rewe und edeka ist
deutschlandweit top ackermann in den
lieferwagen eurer wahl vorbei ich mich
würd's mega freuen wenn ihr sie einfach
mal kaufen will dann das ganze mal
probieren würde weil ich bin ganz
ehrlich das ist die geilste pizza
prosciutto tiefkühlpizza die ich jemals
in meinem ganzen leben gegessen habe ab
wie stehe ich mit meinem namen ich weiß
nicht wer viel und lange lagern aber ich
kanns ja ich habe mich nur wiederholen
probiert sie einfach mal selbst ab
übermorgen gibt es die offiziell in
jedem reden und edeka deutschlandweit
boden meine damen und herren übermorgen
am 15.10
am montag um 15 uhr kommen auch ein
krasses video auf einem kanal am montag
um 15 uhr werden dave und ich in der
regel fahren bei uns jeder näher und
werden dort nach der pizza schauen und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen schwachsinn
machen wir uns ein paar sachen
aufgeschrieben die wir machen wollten
also montag um 15 uhr kommt warum
krasses video um schockierenden
supermarkt vor mal probiert werden die
pizza damit bilde damit auf in ein paar
sekunden später
ladet ihr fotos mit dieser pizza hoch
schreibt mir heißt sie schon gegessen
habe gerne die kommentare wie ihr sie
findet ja mehr gibt es gar nicht zu
sagen
wir sehen uns morgen im neuen video
wieder ciao
[Musik]